Hoff's Gomez for his pear pad welcome
back to dreadout
last episode didn't really go so well
I'm kind of [ __ ] lost in this school
and there's a kitty cat what she wanted
him a look at me come on kid again okay
and we haven't wind been through this
kitty Jesus what is this oh it's a
toilet fantastic
god oh god oh god what's happening in
there hello party in here I hope I love
parties
what was I last night 12 House is
located at attack what yes residential
estate were turned to ashes four other
houses were also heavily damaged by the
blazing fire oh my god did you do this
selfie I did it oh god what is that cat
again shut up
no one likes you I like you actually now
I feel bad loved you you're my only
friend
wait I hear you keep hearing and making
noises and [ __ ] I don't like that it
freaks me out okay oh god [ __ ] this room
really hard Oh God
I'm innocent I would god stop with the
noise please
look oh my god I know you're near you
will never take my baby never Akko Tahoe
Cabo
ah daddy Sakata yes men Gabaldon akuti
daca hon you can't tell me what you do
I'll take any baby any day son nice surf
club alright let's check out what this
kitty cat is doing so making so much
noise
it's like gone get a life that door is
how are ya kidding you want me to go in
here don't you
alright thank you kitty Kuwait what you
don't like selfies
come on I'll Photoshop you I'll make you
look pretty
well [ __ ] alright well um where are we
over up here that's pretty cool I guess
should I jump down no I really shouldn't
the closet door is locked
interesting oh god what was that this
objective scares me that sunset shows
which APA's I am there's a locked closet
there might be something important
inside cut them loose well like I killed
him didn't I like which keys are there
yes hi beautiful
oh god you're ugly my god [ __ ] so many
pictures so I'm gonna picture a where
you're running why are you running don't
run come on come on where did he go
who's a good little piggy
scheisse I had a me oh oh who made that
noise
oh boy that can't be good my lungs are
too sorta music festival that's my
favorite festival best festival um I'm
kind of lost
to be honest goddamn this place creeps
me out
shh shh
Shh oh hello okay what goes in here
oh let's do my best friend how are you I
took your ring really how did I do that
mystical energy that eh
I don't need no mystical lang energies
thank you mrs. skeleton goddamnit scaly
all right well you know what I thank you
for your mystical energy
I'd like some not impolite like that
ugly-ass pink god damn be timely you
found small key oh great
wow wow wow wow
that was so easy to find oh is it oh god
I can't tell a different from your butt
and your face that's when you know
you're ugly okay bring it bring a
Brittany bring it oh oh he brought it
she brought it Brittany brought it
Mayday alright I'm going there has to be
some way to kill that beast and it ain't
with the [ __ ] camera it's real of
baby hey ugly people need love too let's
be honest I know I don't do well
alright let's up with that [ __ ]
closet bet Tom Cruise is hanging around
there got it because he's gay so so
funny oh my god it makes me wanna sing
ah great story Pitts
one of my favorites God can you not be
out of breath right now cuz I kinda need
you to run faster because there's like a
giant beast and we should just jump out
the window I guess that's what I would
do I don't know what are you doing this
situation you actually just look for
keys like if you're in an empty school
and you want to get out you look for a
key for a closet I don't think so you
look for an exit and if you can't find
an exit you break through hey kitty KY
it's not Japanese game but hey what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do okay
I think it's here somewhere I'm not too
sure about it but we'll see it in
Justice space jiffy oh my god
please work yes oh it's better be good
Oh fantastic
hi hi how's everyone doing oh you are
faces oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I got it
got it got it got it all senses Wow
what a fantastic scissor collection my
my I am I am amazed by this all right
let's just find what we need and get the
[ __ ] out of this place oh there's still
the baby yes what was that what was that
what is she doing that better bean oh
god that's an ugly baby god damn you're
ugly
I wasn't stealing anyone's baby uh she's
like touch my baby I like on a [ __ ] oh
god am I gonna have to fight that [ __ ]
cuz I'm not ready oh [ __ ] ugly [ __ ]
where'd she go oh god I hear her
clipping ohh
sayonara [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where's
she
oh god it's so creepy
these noises I can Oh Justin Bieber is
prettier
Oh God
what the park
Oh Oh Oh your hair looks like a [ __ ]
don't you dare touch my hair I'm [ __ ]
fabulous get out get out nobody touch my
hair you're going down now [ __ ] all
this noise just man over that ain't good
Oh No you're [ __ ] sag eat it [ __ ]
okay how many times I gonna have to you
know what I'm taking your baby okay
never mind never mind sorry about that
sorry about the baby bad idea
oh god she's crazy she is out of her
cray-cray and her vajayjay oh god no no
oh god where did she go
you ain't no bro how did I do it then I
do it I don't think God at it if making
it breakdance is winning then I win good
times yeah Oh still ugly
still ugly are we gonna steal that ugly
thing why would anyone touch it god it's
so creepy
Jesus gee buddy be eaten be all right
you know what I'm taking you with me
okay what's your name what's your name
Sally dude you don't look like a Sally
at all oh okay I got a scissor now maybe
that can help me open through some doors
let me check my ups our objective the
camera's flash seem to have distinct
degraded the goes it drops a pair of
scissors
now I can cut the keys loose okay
because I have this a sir
that's not how you pronounce it
Sasser well you're obviously not scholar
because it's actually the old way of
saying it back in the day people call it
sizer but then they realized that it's
[ __ ] numb and they changed it better
better hey I'm old-fashioned call me
old-fashioned let's find a beast Shelby
no not your mom oh my god
hilarious so funny where is this [ __ ]
biggie biggie oh hey pretty beautiful oh
that's the girl be killed isn't it maybe
she was like a hairdresser or some [ __ ]
obviously not a good one she cut the air
air can't be cut oh god what is that
sound stop oh he's sleeping again yes
all right let's approach him very gently
you see in here oh god here yes I don't
like this
alright press hold my hand mine behind
me my lips are you doing all right let's
yes hmm key taken from the neck of a
huge bored beast huge bulbous girl each
boat beef you found the school key does
that mean we can leave cuz that'd be
great
selfie okay let's try the exit first
thus the objective say anything no
object this is like [ __ ] you I don't
like you what's his singing why are you
singing though Oh JA bloody hell better
spit okay alright that's cool that's
great don't want me to go upstairs don't
want to go home safe oh god that is
creepy no no no what the [ __ ] is
happening oh yes the run leg back that
is so creepy
oh my god are we dead yet oh [ __ ] man Oh
panty shot
I didn't mean to oh yeah this happened
last demo
what the Frick man friction let's run
towards the light the lad is a friend oh
my god what the [ __ ] was that
dad I was [ __ ] freaky they really do
have a lot of talent for horror the guys
who made this you don't make [ __ ] like
that over your [ __ ] man you you gotta
be sick and twisted to come up with [ __ ]
oh that's just great you know what I
want to go out still so thank you very
much for the nightmare though thanks for
the nightmares even though they weren't
so great hey hey yeah sweeter whoa
that's not there hmm it's a magic doll
that's awesome
Oh oh god oh god what the hell did I
just do
oh we're back my god I never been so
happy to see you Jared you all right
Oh back home safely as a cow on a string
exit thank you Oh My Jesus pieces
probably pieces all right do you don't
like me Oh God
oh [ __ ] what is she doing she's [ __ ]
with me good job dad
oh I'm so dead hi daddy Dave then hey
stop dancing like that you freaky [ __ ]
[ __ ] that could have gone better breasts
that's okay
oh I can't click the door oh nice
I love eating bugs - fantastic Oh what
the [ __ ]
all these tickles sobbing I'm the
realistic leche
ah
go pitter-pat nope no she got me [ __ ]
got me and they've got made she punched
me oh [ __ ] not that way I suppose I
can't use my camera come on oh god damn
this is so hard I'm gonna make it anyway
from my breath I said for my brows come
on mushy mushy molesting me oh she has
molesting me [ __ ] should have known can
I go here stop laughing it's not funny
dammit is open please for the love of
God go out oh my god oh my god
exit exit for the fun
oh the spiderweb [ __ ] you spiderweb and
[ __ ] your bit Oh goddamn she got more
tricks oh nice oh I love me our house
oh no the controls are all [ __ ] oh
come on
no way
how am I gonna live the controls are
inverted oh [ __ ] I gotta take a [ __ ] no
I don't I don't
there's exit goddamn mouth [ __ ] up my
control oh god don't be here don't be
here please I gotta see you hi hi friend
fantastic day oh no no what is she gotta
be there
oh no why are you doing to go Eddie next
no don't laugh at me I don't want to die
now this is the wrong way it's a dead
end
why do I even try she's such a B word
you're such a B word
don't touch me no no [ __ ] way that
I'm gonna die here [ __ ] you [ __ ] a does
[ __ ] everyone run just one just run
Linda let me know whatever okay come on
come on I need some part in surrett
Jesus this is the moment when I would
look back oh it's like crawling all over
me I love it
that's what she said yes oh god what the
[ __ ] was that
you are really mean you know what go
away
sparkle Sparkle sunshine [ __ ] oh this
game is hard man oh come on give me a
break
bye bye room
love the style in this day
haha
goddamnit
I was hoping for more so in case you
don't get it already
this is act 1 I don't know how many
they're gonna get do uh but yeah I guess
we're gonna have to wait for more it's
one of those huh still I gotta say I'm
pretty impressed with this game it is a
small project after all I don't know it
is a kickstarter product after all let's
put it that way so for for these guys to
pull in something that looks really I I
think it looks nice I know some people
are like literally it no graphics are
weird but it's it's like a tribute to
old-school horror games in my opinion
and that's pretty cool so I'm definitely
looking forward to more let me know if
you feel the same way like we like if
you do I hit the sky icon road today
Bros and I'll see you in the act 2 or
next video that I make alright fantastic
alright rest see ya